I'm very keen to talk to you about rail
strikes of course but I just want to
start with a story that the times is
reporting which is saying that the
limits on taking liquids into airports
onto airplanes are going to be stopped
by 2024 is that correct well I
understand that stories off the back of
some commentary from one of the bosses
of an airport and I'm afraid you'll know
our usual practice on security matters
is we don't comment on security matters
I think it's quite important I'm now
responsible for setting the security
regime for our Aviation sector so you
know if there are any changes coming
we'll set those out for people in due
course
um but at the moment the the regime is
as it is with the strict limits on the
limit liquids people can take on planes
I mean the times are saying that because
of advancements in Scanners the limits
are going to be unnecessary I mean that
would be quite welcome to use for
travelers wouldn't it well look I'm sure
I'm sure people would like to not have
those limits but they're in place for a
very good reason if that should change
in the future then obviously we'll set
that out but you know the security
regime is in place for a reason it's
important that people follow it
um you know we always keep these matters
under review but at the moment the
position is as it is okay and now you're
meeting with the rmt tomorrow the rail
Union what's your message going to be
well look the reason for meeting very
clearly I'm not negotiating with them
that's very clearly for the trade unions
and the employers Network Rail and the
train operating companies but I do think
in this in this case it's important to
meet with the unions um this isn't just
these these strikes are not just about
pay this is about long-running talks
that are actually about delivering rail
reform people will know that because of
the pandemic significant number of
people have stopped using Railways you
know the number of passengers is around
80 percent of what it was pre-pandemic
that set up some very significant
financial challenges for the industry I
want a thriving viable financially
sustainable Railway that's the only way
you actually secure the jobs of the
rmt's members so it's the same same
shared agenda and I want to set that out
to Mr Lynch and the other Trade union
leaders about that being our ambition
and I would urge him and the other trade
unions to get around the table I'd urge
them to call off the strikes get back
around the table with the employers try
and Hammer out some of those reforms
that are necessary in which deliver the
savings that can then help pay for pay
Rises for his members and deliver a
better service you know these strikes
are going to be damaging for passengers
they're going to be redisruptive for the
first Christmas we've had that hasn't
been impacted by covid a big hit for the
hospitality sector how much will it cost
the economy you think well look it it's
going to be a very significant cost it's
going to be no I haven't but we've
already heard some very significant cost
estimates from the hospital from UK
Hospitality you know that's a sector
that was hit during covid you know I
spoke up for that sector when I was on
the back benches you know the Prime
Minister when he was Chancellor tried to
protect that sector and these rail
strikes are going to be very damaging
can be damaging for the people in the
rail industry who are going to lose
their pay and their their overtime but
they're going to also hit people in the
hospitality sector they're going to be
damaging for passengers and I would
still urge the unions to call off the
strikes get back around the table and
try to hammer out an agreement and
that's what I'm going to be saying to Mr
Lynch when I meet him tomorrow I mean
you know you're saying there that you're
not involved in the talks that they're
between the rmt and the train operating
companies I guess some of our viewers
will be thinking hang on you're the
transport secretary why don't you get
involved surely this is exactly the
minute for you to actually try and make
a difference you know just look at the
dates of the strikes the 13th 14th 16th
17th of December the third fourth sixth
seventh of January just when people as
you say hospitality industry people can
be trying to find their fam going to see
their families they're going to be
wanting to get into the Christmas spirit
why don't you get involved well look
they are very damaging and and I am
involved in the sense I'm going to set
out very clearly what our ambition is
why it's important that the unions reach
a deal with the employers but the detail
matters here so it's about the specific
reforms that Network rail need to see in
their maintenance operations it's about
the specific reformers we need to see in
having a seven-day Railway more flexible
Railway and it's about pay as well what
do you think of inflation inflation's 11
is it fair for uh transport workers to
be expecting to see their pay matching
inflation well look the difficult
challenge that we've seen big challenge
for the economy uh because of covid so
that was a you know one in 300 year hit
to the economy and we're recovering from
that we've seen a uh at the made in
Russia challenge you know because of
their illegal invasions do you think
that the pay for transport workers
should match so so the reason why I'm
putting in context is because I think
the context matters
um the most important thing for
everybody in the country whether you're
a transport worker or or some other
public sector worker or someone in the
private set is that we get inflation
under control that's why the chancellor
to set out a credible economic package
last week
so that's the concept well and so that
means that although I completely
understand why people facing these cost
of living pressures want more pay the
government is simply not in a position
to pay inflation pay Rises and if we
were to do so the danger is that we
would embed inflation and that wouldn't
actually be in anyone's long-term
interest what's in people's interests is
that we get inflation driven out of the
system so that it comes back down to a
lower level we see interest rates then
falling that's how we get a long-term
sustainable position I accept it's
difficult for people and a Chancellor
made that clear last week none of this
is easy but there is a context here and
I think that's important for for the
rail unions to understand as well as
other people who Who oversee are
pressing for higher pay Rises now MIT
Lynch of course takes a different
position on this and many other things
as well to be fair now I just want to
have a look at what he said earlier he
said the Secretary of State the rather
than City on his hands has got to get
down to the serious business of creating
a settlement yesterday I was told by the
most senior person working for the
training operation companies that he's
been stopped from offered offering us a
deal he's being prevented from doing
that by the Department of Transport and
it seems they're stuck on the idea of
continuing this dispute into the new
year is that right that the DFT in the
department for transport and yourself as
a secretary of state are blocking the
train operating companies for offering
no look at the end of that quote there
we're Mick Lynch was talking about us
wanting this to go into new we
absolutely do not I I don't want any
strikes to take place
I want the dispute to be settled so I'm
not going to get into
um you know throwing accusations around
I want to have a sensible conversation
with him tomorrow where I set out the
context of what we're trying to achieve
which is recognizing the railway
Industries had a big hit because of the
pound the imperative is to get reform so
that we get more people using the
railway we drive up Revenue we drive out
cost we deliver the ability for the
train operating companies and network
rail to be able to offer better salaries
and wages to the people that work in the
industry and that can only be achieved
by the trade unions in the employers
getting around the table and hammering
out those reforms and I want to I want
to try and help facilitate that and
that's the message that I'm going to be
delivering to him tomorrow now in other
news the Supreme Court ruled today that
the Scottish government can't call an
independence referendum on its own
unilaterally Westminster has to agree to
it as well
so if the democratically elected
Scottish government requests permission
to call an independence referendum would
you grant it well look the government
made it very clear today the Prime
Minister has asked this question it will
vary in solvent prime minister's
discretion State and he made it very
clear look the priority for I think the
people of Scotland and indeed everyone
in the UK is to focus on the issues
facing the country which is deal with
the economic challenge protect people
from energy price Rises
um and the consequences of the war in
Ukraine and that requires the UK
government and the Scottish government
working together and I think the really
um a positive thing that the Prime
Minister did he was the first Prime
Minister for many years to go to the
British Irish Council he sat down with
um the Scottish first minister they had
a very sensible conversation about about
priorities and I think that partnership
working is what we need to see and
that's that's the priority for the UK
government you talk about the priorities
of the Scottish people but Scotland has
voted for the Scottish national party
that they argue is their mandate I mean
the clues in the name of the Scottish
national party they're not standing on a
platform to do anything other than
deliver Independence well I think if you
look at actually what the Scottish
people want they want the government
actually to be focused on both
governments to be focused on the
day-to-day challenges they voted in the
Scottish national party who is in their
manifestation to use their powers and
you know the Scottish Parliament has a
tremendous set of powers to deal with
the things that it is responsible for
which is you know running the Health
Service in Scotland running the
education system in Scotland delivering
better Services is there a line which
you would say okay this is when a
referendum should be allowed what is
that red line is it for example you know
the s p getting a majority in the
Scottish Parliament well look our
position is very clear we think the
position at the moment is that the UK
government the Scottish government
should be working together focused on
the priorities that are facing the
United Kingdom is their route to a
referendum that you can spell out well
look we we had a a referendum in 2014
and the the position that was agreed and
that was settled not not just between uh
Westminster and the Scottish government
but actually agreed across Civic
Scotland was that that was a once in a
generation referendum and we've
respected the result of that referendum
and that referendum was that Scotland
stayed in the United Kingdom and that
means Scotland has two governments it
has a Scottish government and it has the
UK government and those governments
should work together I understand the
results of the referendum but the
question is is there a route to another
referendum well the priority at the
moment is for the two governments to
work together on the issues facing the
United Kingdom
and those are the issues that I set out
which are the economic challenges
protecting people from energy price
Rises and dealing with the economic
challenges and then delivering on the
public services that we deliver you know
the UK government's responsible for
delivering those in England the Scottish
government's responsible for delivering
those in Scotland and the Prime Minister
will work with the first minister in
Partnership to deliver on those
priorities for for the people in both
parts of the United Kingdom okay thank
you very much indeed for being on the
program pleasure